ورقه كبيره جدا متعبه لان
الواحد
يبحث في
لا نقول لا شيء ولكن يبحث في
موضوع متشعب معظم ما كتب عنه لا يستند الى
[موسيقى]
مصادر رصينا سبب غياب المصادر الصينه ان
لدينا روايه واحده فقط اللي هي الروايه
الامريكيه باعتبار انه فيه لوسوسه همم
القضيه مرفوعه في محاكم امريكا على بعض
المواطنين السعوديين اللي همم المتهمين في
هذه القضيه
واضافه الى شخصيه مجهولتين واحده من لبنان
همم من ايران همم ما في روايه رسميه
سعوديه ما في الروايه رسميه ايرانيه
الخبر والعن حزب الله بشكل
المملكه في روايه رسميه من ايران همم ما
في تبني صريح من همم جهه معينه
كل من لديه اجنده من الكتاب او الباحثين
يحاول ان يجير الحادثه
لخدمه اجنده في روايات متباينه منها من
يتهم مواطنين السعوديين متواطئين مع
المخابرات الايرانيه ومنها من يتهم
التنظيم القاعده بل وسمي بعض الاسماء يسمي
يعني عبد الباري عطوان في كتابه
افتر بن لادن الكايده ذالكس جينيريشن ما
بعد بنلادن
القاعده يتهم ااا ابو ليث الليبي ان هو
خلف العمليه الطيبه
ونفس الكلام لما نشوف اشياء اخرى نشوف
الابرز المصادر هي الروايه الامريكيه
باعتبار انه لويس
السابق نشر تفاصيل كثيره
لم يدعي انه السند الى ملف القضايا لكن
الرئيس السابق الى جهاز امني
لابد ان يكون من فراغ على كل حال